i want to bring up this story from the
other day it's uh many of you may have
seen it trump and bill o'reilly got
booed after telling audience they got
booster shots and then trump is like no
no no don't do that you're playing
anything blah blah and i'm like
what's funny about this story is that
many on the left are like haha trump got
boosted and i'm like okay like i don't
i'm not mad i don't care
he's an older guy maybe that made sense
for him sure but they live in this
bubble world where they think all of
trump supporters are in a cult yes all
of his voters are cultists meanwhile
it's like most of his base is kind of
like whatever and then some are like
that's stupid and they boo him but
i don't know i don't care
bill riley can trump they can do
whatever they want
but this actually debunks a lot of that
narrative
that's why i just think it's funny
shouldn't they be like wow hey wait a
minute i was told that trump's base are
all a bunch of zealot maga q anon people
but there are actually people who aren't
agreeing with him and he himself is
vaccinate is boosted
there's a disconnect between
trump's supposed to be this cult leader
right right well being the genius
marketer that he is as soon as that as
soon as that little pocket of booze
happened he goes very small group of
people right over there anyway
but also during his speech he was making
a lot of assertions based off no data no
information at all he said this would
have been like the spanish flu if it
wasn't for me we got to take credit i
want credit we got credit for for doing
this
what did you do
after your you know your product that
you stream rolled and you threw a lot of
money into uh got out there what
happened case has gone up debts have
gone up you know what are you dancing on
like how are you going to be making all
these assertions um and a lot of people
aren't happy with his statements and i
think you know his statements and what
he did with dr fauci is going to lead to
a situation where a lot of his supporter
base i think legitimately is not going
to be following him now the corporate
media saying that he's an anti-vaxxer
and all of his followers or anti-vaxxers
again it's just hyperbolic dribble
because he's he's clearly on a different
side and and clearly not afraid to
express those ideas you see that that
interview he did where he said he didn't
fire fouchy because the left would have
lost it and then a bunch of people on
the right were like trump admits he
didn't fire fauci because he was scared
of the left the left already lost it a
number of times during his entire
presidency and with absolute nonsense
trump should have realized his people
around him should have realized hey you
can't appease any of these people yeah
they want
war but there might be something else
hanging in the balance here because
today we also found out that trump flew
on uh epstein's plane six more times
than previously believed so if you're
hanging out with epstein who's an
extortionist who's a blackmailer there
could be also something something else
happening behind the scenes that could
translate into this kind of uh
misunderstanding and trump you know
pushing a lot of policies that are very
in favor of the establishment that
essentially do hurt the general public
and the middle class i like the
conspiracy theory that trump was part of
the establishment the whole time
because what he was able to do as a
candidate was get people like alex jones
to support a republican candidate for
the presidency and to get a whole bunch
of the people who are not attached
politically to join the political frame
join a party and become part of that
system
right yeah absolutely and and you know
when it comes to politics it's dirty
there's a lot of other things happening
behind the scenes there's a lot of
special interest there's a lot of
multinational corporations throwing
around a lot of money there's a lot of
blackmail going around as well so i
don't think we're seeing the full actual
story here of what's actually going on
and that's just my own perspective i
could be wrong prove prove me wrong if
you think i'm wrong but
again
what what trump has done is something
that i haven't uh been supportive of
i've criticized him ever since he sat
down with henry kissinger he promised a
lot in my opinion he definitely
under-delivered but that's my
perspective i know a lot of people are
going to be disagreeing with me but
that's okay that's that's your
perspective prove me wrong with some
data and some facts uh but that's how i
saw it myself personally and i think a
lot of other people who are paying
attention to the news to the reality of
the situation are also feeling the same
way because how can you not especially
with you know julian assange yeah
kind of cherry on top right but trump
trump was just an imperfect avatar for
people's anger right you know so when
bernie sanders lost he a lot of bernie
supporters voted for trump and this is
something that the progressives will
never want to admit but it's true i was
in anaheim california and there were
three dudes one was older two were
younger and they were explaining that
you know they were trump supporters but
they were bernie supporters until
hillary stole the you know they say
until until the dnc
you know went in favor of hillary he'll
put it that way
and uh they got physically attacked
the the people there started attacking
them and they were running and they were
spitting on them and stuff like that and
i'm like that's really amazing this guy
said he was a bernie supporter he said
he felt bernie had more experience that
bernie was a politician and trump was
not and that bernie would know how to
navigate these systems bernie was in
favor of border security bernie was in
favor of helping the working class but
as soon as hillary came in he was like
nope donald trump's the answer because
you know
hillary clinton is going to be open
borders hillary clinton is going to be
all the worst things war conflict you
know extracting our jobs and placing
them overseas trump was the only option
trump was talking about investigating
911 holding saudi arabia accountable for
it auditing the federal reserve
releasing the jfk cia documents
everyone's mind was blown he was like
he's bucking the system really and then
you know the reality of of all those
promises was a lot you know when he was
it's because trump flying in his plane
over dc looking down at the world and
then telling everybody i am going to
clean this place up is very different
from when the plane lands and he takes
one step and his foot sinks three feet
into muck and scum and he goes like what
do i do here
it happens to a lot of these people run
they say i'm gonna do all these things
i'm gonna do this that or otherwise and
then trump gets in and he was
like just dredging through that muck
trying to make the other side worse
still with a lot of presidents they get
in the muck they they don't follow
through on all their promises
trump not only had the muck but he had
the establishment democrat and activists
you know like lassoing him and pulling
him back at the same time and they're
still doing it today throughout his
entire presidency he was being in
presidency he was investigated then he
would they impeached him and they
impeached him again then you get ukraine
gay russia gate all of these scandals
preventing him from being able to do
anything and the left likes it they're
like good obstruct him but i'll tell you
this you cannot have a country where all
you have is two sides obstructing each
other and nothing's getting done because
eventually when the obstruction stops
working people start hitting each other
that sounds like a dream for me
government obstructing each other not
doing anything that sounds awesome i
have a difference so they rip each other
apart um
well if you know if they don't let one
side get too strong to hurt the other
side if they just keep keeping each
other in check i think that would be the
optimal situation i don't see that
happening i see them more working in
tandem and from my perspective you know
trump got in that swamp he was like okay
i'll fight this a little bit and then
like midway he's like oh this is a mud
bath this is nice and he started rubbing
the
the the dc mud all over himself and kind
of enjoying it and then be like maybe i
should uh it's kind of nice just being
in this muddy i think i think one way to
put it is trump's always had a bit of a
muck on him yeah i mean yeah and when he
got into the swamp he's he looked at
some swamp monsters and one swamp
monster was like trump hi ron bolton and
then trump was like
he goes wait a minute are you a swamp
monster i swear i'm not
okay john and then he looks over at
another swamp monster and he's like i'm
gonna invade iran and he's like you're
hired yeah and fauci was there the whole
time and trump was like i'd fire that
swamp monster but the p the swamp
monsters over there really like him so i
won't yeah and jared kushner as well i
mean there's a lot of crazy stories that
came out surrounding jared kushner and
his involvement and sphere of influence
pushing a lot of policies that were
absolutely not popular at all and there
was a lot of opportunity there and i i
think that's why a lot of people felt
let down but let's be honest here he
still did some okay things uh we
shouldn't be too
uh one-sided and and not just always
attack him we should admit that he also
did push for very populous policies he
had a very uh unique china policy no new
work he focused on american jobs and
again we have to start seeing things
through the lens of of uh outside of our
political gangs you know what's funny
though no you shouldn't be in the bloods
you shouldn't be the crips but you
should see that this violence is just
absolutely stupid and then both sides
are playing you i'll tell you what's
funny is that trump did try to end a lot
of our wars yeah but not all of them he
did try to get us out of the middle east
and stuff like that it's kind of sad
that where we are as a country is the
president who doesn't start any new wars
gets praise because we're so used to all
the president's starting wars it's the
norm yeah yeah and and and i understand
trump was actually pulling back a little
bit but imagine if we got a president on
day one just signed a bunch of executive
orders saying we hereby are ending these
excursions and we're gonna be bringing
troops back and we're gonna be
withdrawing all that stuff even trump
didn't do that but trump did i believe
try in many ways and that's because when
he was you know
marching through the muck and everyone
and he's trying really hard to get
through it he was determined i am going
to carry out my promise i'm going to
build that wall i'm going to you know
withdraw from afghanistan and then as
soon as he
leaves the swamp and joe biden walks
back in joe biden started rolling around
like a like a pig in
ish if you know what i mean he was happy
he was like oh swamp i'm home you know
started getting his energy back as the
swamp returned to life to his you know
rotting corrupt body and then he was
like let's botch afghanistan so he can
destabilize the region further and then
there you go but continuing that syria
policy was just insane continuing the
yemen policy also another thing no one
really talks about the worst
humanitarian crisis according to many
international organizations in the world
because of the u.s saudi arabian
coalition that's literally fighting
proxy iranian forces against proxy al
qaeda saudi arabian forces we were on
the side of al qaeda even though
associated press was writing articles
saying how yeah you know the the saudi
coalition comes in there they tell al
qaeda to step back they bring in the
media they say we conquered al-qaeda
meanwhile they were working with them in
yemen and part of american foreign
policy as well as you know being on the
side of the rebel groups i mean bombing
syria it was just the wild his foreign
policy because he himself called himself
a globalist and a populist you can't be
both and i think he
he represented both ideas but he also
contradicted himself a lot and fought
himself thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you